Kalau korang putar bola mengelilingi satu paksi kemudian paksi lain, hasilnya tak sama macam buat dua putaran tu dalam urutan terbalik.
Harini dalam Qiskit in the classroom kita akan tengok apa kena mengena bola ni dengan komputer kuantum dan salah satu prinsip paling famous
dalam mekanik kuantum — prinsip ketakpastian.
Selamat datang ke Qiskit in the classroom, siri video di mana kita pecahkan konsep asas yang korang mungkin jumpa dalam kursus berkaitan Quantum Computing.
Setiap video ada modul interaktif yang dilink dalam
deskripsi bawah, so pastikan korang tengok. Harini kita bincang prinsip ketakpastian Heisenberg. Kalau korang
pernah dengar pasal ni sebelum ni, korang mungkin pernah dengar jenaka lama pasal Heisenberg. Suatu hari dia ditahan semasa memandu dan polis tanya dia, "Tahukah
awak laju mana awak pergi?" Heisenberg jawab, "Tak tahu, tapi saya tahu tepat-tepat di mana saya berada." Ini lebih kurang
prinsip ketakpastian Heisenberg dalam ringkasan — korang tak boleh tahu serentak kedudukan dan momentum zarah dengan
ketepatan yang sempurna. Ia selalu ditulis macam ni: Delta x kali Delta p lebih besar daripada
atau sama dengan h per 2, di mana Delta X dan Delta P ialah
ketakpastian dalam kedudukan dan momentum, dan H ialah pemalar asas yang sangat kecil dalam mekanik kuantum.
Heisenberg dapat ketaksamaan ini pada tahun 1927 ketika dia cuba bayangkan macam mana nak ukur kedudukan elektron. Kalau
korang pantulkan foton daripadanya untuk tengok di mana ia berada, foton tu akan pasti tendang elektron tu dan ganggu momentum
dia. Ini bukan sekadar pernyataan tentang pengukuran yang mengganggu sistem — ia memberitahu kita bahawa ada had asas
tentang berapa banyak yang kita boleh tahu pasal alam semula jadi. Ini adalah satu contoh prinsip yang lebih luas dipanggil komplementariti, yang
mengatakan bahawa aspek-aspek tertentu alam semula jadi tak serasai antara satu sama lain dan tak boleh diperhatikan
serentak. Contohnya, objek kuantum kadang-kadang berkelakuan macam zarah dan kadang-kadang macam gelombang,
tapi korang tak boleh perhatikan kedua-dua kelakuan serentak. Hubungan kedudukan dan momentum Heisenberg hanya satu daripada
banyak set ciri komplementari. Ketakpastian wujud ini ada kaitan dengan cara kita memandang sifat macam
kedudukan dan momentum dalam mekanik kuantum. Bukannya fikir X dan P sebagai pembolehubah atau sifat intrinsik
yang setiap zarah ada, dalam mekanik kuantum kedudukan dan momentum adalah operator. Ia bukan sifat sesebuah
sistem, tapi benda yang boleh korang lakukan pada sistem. Nak tahu kedudukan zarah sekarang memerlukan korang untuk melakukan
operasi pada sistem tu dan buat pengukuran. Operasi ni boleh affect keputusan operasi-operasi lain yang berikutnya.
Sebagai analogi, fikir tentang sekeping kayu kering. Ia ada banyak sifat macam
kedudukan, saiz, bentuk. Ia juga ada sifat boleh dibakar dan boleh terapung dalam air. Kalau kayu ni adalah objek kuantum,
sifat-sifat ni bukanlah benda yang korang boleh tahu secara a priori. Sebaliknya kita katakan ia adalah
perkara boleh diperhatikan — benda yang boleh korang pelajari tentang sistem kalau korang lakukan sesuatu operasi padanya. So korang kena kenakan operator
kebolehterbakaran atau kebolehterapungan, yang memerlukan korang cuba bakar kayu tu atau letak ia dalam
air untuk tengok sama ada ia terapung. Kini keputusan setiap operator ni bergantung pada urutan korang kenakan diorang. Kalau
korang uji kebolehterbakaran dulu, kayu tu akan terbakar jadi abu dan korang tak boleh uji sama ada ia terapung. Tapi kalau korang uji
kebolehterapungan dulu, ia akan jadi terlalu basah untuk dibakar. Kita katakan bahawa operator kebolehterbakaran dan
kebolehterapungan tak komut — urutan operasi adalah penting. Ini membawa kepada had asas
tentang betapa baiknya dua perkara boleh diperhatikan ni boleh diketahui tentang sekeping kayu, sebab kita tak boleh kata dengan pasti sama ada ia
boleh dibakar atau terapung tanpa tahu konteks pengukuran tu. Sudah tentu dengan sekeping kayu sebenar korang boleh
potong ia separuh dan uji kedua-dua sifat tu serentak, tapi korang tak boleh buat benda macam tu dengan zarah kuantum. Analogi
tentang kayu ni hanyalah analogi. Ketakpastian adalah benda yang unik pada kuantum. X dan P juga tak komut,
dan sifat tak komut inilah yang membawa kepada prinsip ketakpastian Heisenberg. Secara umum, mana-mana dua operator
yang tak komut akan ada prinsip ketakpastian tersendiri. Bentuk umum prinsip ketakpastian boleh
ditulis macam ni: Delta a kali Delta
B lebih besar daripada atau sama dengan
seperdua kali ada a dan b, di mana
kurungan ini dipanggil
komutator, dan ia sama dengan perbezaan antara guna dulu a kemudian
b dan guna dulu b kemudian a. Kurungan sudut-sudut
ni menandakan korang ambil apa yang dipanggil nilai jangkaan bagi apa yang ada di dalamnya — lebih kurang kalau korang buat pengukuran yang sama
banyak-banyak kali, nilai jangkaan ialah purata bagi semua ukuran tu. Harini kita akan
benar-benar uji dan sahkan prinsip ketakpastian ni pada komputer kuantum IBM. Kita akan tengok tiga perkara boleh diperhatikan berbeza
bagi qubit, tunjukkan bahawa operator diorang tak komut, dan akhirnya kita akan dapat buktikan bahawa prinsip
ketakpastian berlaku untuk perkara boleh diperhatikan qubit ni. Pertama sekali, ringkasan ringkas tentang cara berguna untuk bayangkan keadaan kuantum
qubit. Ia boleh diwakilkan oleh vektor yang menghala ke sesuatu tempat pada sfera yang dipanggil sfera Bloch. Aku dah cerita
pasal ni dalam video sebelum ni yang dilink dalam deskripsi, tapi aku akan bagi ringkasan cepat di sini juga. Ni dia
sfera Bloch. Setiap vektor diparameterkan oleh dua sudut Theta dan F.
Keadaan sifar ada di kutub Utara dan keadaan satu ada di kutub Selatan, dan superposisi sama bagi 0 dan 1 ada
di suatu tempat sepanjang Khatulistiwa di mana f sama dengan fasa relatif antara dua bahagian
superposisi. So keadaan ini di sini akan sama
dengan 1 per punca 2 dikali 0 tambah e kepada kuasa i phi dikali 1, di mana i ialah
fasa tu. Bila kita ukur perkara boleh diperhatikan qubit, hasilnya sentiasa salah satu daripada dua pilihan yang sepadan dengan dua
keadaan yang mungkin bagi qubit. Untuk eksperimen yang kita nak buat ni kita akan tengok tiga perkara boleh diperhatikan dan
operator yang sepadan dengan diorang: X, Y, dan Z. Bila korang ukur mana-mana perkara boleh diperhatikan ni korang dapat sama ada tambah satu atau
tolak satu, dengan kebarangkalian untuk setiap yang bergantung pada sudut antara vektor qubit pada sfera Bloch dan
WEBVTT
paksi pengukuran. Macam yang korang jangkakan, Z mengukur sepanjang paksi Z, X sepanjang X,
dan Y sepanjang y. Sekarang ingat kita bercakap pasal perkara boleh diperhatikan sebab dengan sistem kuantum
kita tak boleh lagi tahu benda-benda tentang sistem tu tanpa mengukurnya.
Dan setiap perkara boleh diperhatikan ada operasi yang sepadan sebab pengukuran memerlukan operasi. Mungkin tak obvious tapi
rupanya operasi yang dipanggil operator yang sepadan dengan setiap perkara boleh diperhatikan x, y dan z ini ialah
putaran Pi mengelilingi paksi masing-masing. So X ialah putaran mengelilingi X, Y
mengelilingi Y, dan Z mengelilingi Z. So untuk tengok sama ada operator-operator ni komut atau tidak kita boleh semak sama ada putaran
pada sfera komut. Kalau ya, prinsip ketakpastian tak berlaku dan kita akan boleh tahu X, Y dan Z tentang qubit
dengan ketepatan sempurna. Kalau tidak komut, kita akan dapat jumpa hubungan ketakpastian baru untuk qubit. Tengok
titik pada bola ni semasa aku putar dulu mengelilingi X kemudian mengelilingi Y. Ia berakhir
di sini. Sekarang jom cuba dalam urutan terbalik — aku putar dulu mengelilingi Y dan
kemudian mengelilingi X. Ia berakhir di sini. So memang tak komut. Itu bermakna
kita tak boleh tahu serentak nilai X, Y dan Z qubit yang tepat — kita akan ada
hubungan ketakpastian. Kita tak akan perincikan butiran di sini tapi akhirnya kita dapat tiga hubungan ketakpastian berbeza.
So kita ada Delta x kali Delta Y
lebih besar atau sama dengan Z. Delta y dikali Delta Z lebih besar atau sama
dengan X, dan Delta Z dikali Delta X lebih besar atau sama
dengan Y. So hasil darab mana-mana dua ketakpastian ini sentiasa lebih besar atau
sama dengan nilai jangkaan perkara boleh diperhatikan yang ketiga. Jom guna Qiskit untuk tengok apa yang
berlaku bila kita cuba ukur Z dan X bagi keadaan sifar. Mengukur Z mudah — ia adalah asas standard yang dipanggil
pengukuran komputer kuantum sentiasa sepanjang Z secara lalai. Tapi untuk ukur X kita kena lakukan apa yang dipanggil
perubahan asas — lebih kurang putar sfera Bloch supaya X kini menghala ke atas di mana Z pernah menghala. Untuk buat ni
kita guna gate Hadamard. So circuit Quantum penuh akan nampak macam ni — kita ukur dalam Z, kenakan Hadamard,
dan kemudian ukur dalam X. Kalau kita guna Qiskit primitive sampler untuk jalankan eksperimen ni banyak kali kita
akan dapat histogram keputusan ukuran yang nampak macam ni untuk pengukuran Z
dan macam ni untuk pengukuran dalam X. So macam yang korang nampak kita ukur
qubit berada dalam keadaan sifar sepanjang Z dengan hampir 100% kepastian, tapi
sepanjang X kita hampir tak tahu apa-apa pasal keadaan qubit — ia diukur sama ada sifar atau satu dengan kebarangkalian
yang sama, bermakna ketakpastian kita dalam X lebih kurang sebesar yang mungkin. Itu bagi kita
sedikit gambaran tentang pertukaran ketakpastian ni, tapi kita boleh buat lebih sikit lagi pada komputer kuantum kita. Kita boleh guna
Qiskit primitive yang dipanggil estimator untuk cari nilai jangkaan perkara boleh diperhatikan X, Y dan Z kita dan
ketakpastian dalam setiap. Jom cuba untuk keadaan yang menghala dalam arah plus X pada sfera Bloch. Kita guna estimator
untuk kira ketakpastian dalam x dan z untuk keadaan ni dan nilai jangkaan
y. Dengan keadaan ni kita dapat keputusan ini dari Qiskit. Bila kita ambil hasil darab dua
ketakpastian dalam X dan Y kita nampak bahawa seperti yang dijangkakan, ia lebih besar daripada nilai mutlak
nilai jangkaan y. Tapi ini hanya untuk satu keadaan tertentu. Kita nak pastikan ketaksamaan ini
berlaku untuk semua keadaan qubit. So jom guna estimator sekali lagi tapi kali ni kita akan minta ia imbas melalui nilai parameter
dan cari nilai jangkaan pada setiap nilai parameter yang kita bagi. Di sini parameter yang kita nak
imbas ialah sudut Theta pada sfera Bloch supaya kita semak ketaksamaan untuk semua keadaan qubit yang terletak pada
lengkok yang bersilang dengan satah XZ. Bila kita buat ni kita dapat plot sebagai fungsi sudut Theta. Lengkung merah
adalah hasil darab dua ketakpastian dan lengkung oren ialah nilai jangkaan y. Seperti yang dijangkakan
hasil darab ketakpastian dalam x dan z jauh lebih tinggi daripada nilai jangkaan y. Tapi itu tak
susah sangat nak penuhi ketaksamaan sebab nilai jangkaan y sangat rendah — ia sifar untuk semua keadaan pada
lengkok ni. Jom buat imbasan serupa melalui nilai Theta tapi bukannya imbas dalam satah XZ kita akan tetapkan f sama dengan pi per
4 so kita tengok keadaan qubit yang terletak pada lengkok berbeza pada sfera. Di sini kita nampak ketaksamaan diuji
lebih sikit sebab lengkung oren dan lengkung merah lebih rapat, tapi merah sentiasa di atas oren
dan prinsip ketakpastian masih berlaku. Kita belum semak semua keadaan lagi tapi harapnya korang dah mula dapat
gambaran. Ada ketakbolehketahuan asas tentang mana-mana dua aspek komplementari sistem kuantum
termasuk qubit yang kita guna ni. Prinsip ketakpastian paksa kita untuk akui bahawa tak kira
sekeras mana kita cuba, tak kira sekrut mana pengukuran kita, kita tidak akan pernah tahu segalanya dengan ketepatan sempurna.
Memang tak ada jalan keluarnya. Kalau korang tak percaya aku — atau pun kalau korang percaya — aku cabar korang pergi tengok modul
yang dilink dalam deskripsi dan cuba kalahkan prinsip ketakpastian. Terima kasih kerana menonton, jumpa korang next time.